well a community in Utah is mourning
after its mayor was killed in
Afghanistan while he was deployed with
the National Guard his body is scheduled
to arrive in the US tonight 39 year-old
Brent Taylor died Saturday after one of
his afghan trainees shot him Afghan
forces reportedly killed the attacker
Taylor leaves behind a wife and seven
children John Blackstone is in North
Ogden Utah at the site of a growing
tribute John good morning good morning
well I'm here on heroes Boulevard
it's where banners are displayed
honoring community members who are
serving in the military and as you can
see this one paying tribute to Brent
Taylor has now become a memorial paying
tribute to a fallen soldier who was also
this city's beloved mayor as a married
father of seven an Army National Guard
major and mayor of North Ogden Utah
Brent Taylor devoted his life to helping
others there are three great loyalties
that have guided my life and everything
in it God family and country in January
Taylor announced on Facebook that he
would be taking a leave of absence as
mayor in order to deploy overseas for a
fourth time his mission training the
staff of an Afghan battalion command but
with just two months left in his
year-long tour Taylor was killed by an
Afghan soldier in an insider attack
I know his incursion I go but he
volunteered because he thought he could
do something good Taylor's best friend
Toby molesky says his children lost a
role model and the country has lost a
hero he did what he did because he
wanted to make sure there were no one
justices Taylor is the third u.s.
soldier to be killed in an insider
attack in Afghanistan since July 17
years after 9/11 there are still some 15
thousand US troops in the country many
whose main job is to train and advise
Afghan forces
nearly half of this year's American
combat deaths in Afghanistan have
reportedly come from suspected insider
attacks Michael O'Hanlon is a researcher
and author who specializes in u.s.
military strategy it's a deliberate
tactic
on their part to kill people like mayor
Taylor and to try to therefore affect
American will this tragic attack brings
home the need to ask ourselves again is
there really a light at the end of the
tunnel
Taylor is being remembered as a man who
wanted to make the world a better place
City Administrator John call worked with
him my heart bleeds for those kids I
just can't imagine what they're gonna go
through less than a week before his
death Taylor wrote what would be his
final post on Facebook urging all
Americans to vote saying regardless of
party we have more that unites us than
divides us Gayle and we have to keep
reminding ourselves about that thank you
John it listen the death of any American
soldier fighting for our country is very
painful but there's something about this
one that raises all sorts of questions
you look at his family photo number one
that it was his fourth tour that he
wanted to go back again and that he was
killed from someone on the inside I
don't know how you ever protect when
you're attacked from someone on the
inside that way he and his brothers all
enlisted and after the September 11th
attacks and their dedication and loyalty
to this country and when he left when he
left to deploy this time people from the
town lined the streets to applaud him
applauded him mm-hmm
their need to refocus on on the service
and sacrifice that men and women are
still facing today these wars are not
over yeah the guy and the report raises
a good question is there light at the
end of the tunnel very take a little
question a very difficult question